OUR WORK ETHIC IN THE
UNITED STATES, SO HERE WE ARE.
THE WAR ON WORK.
IF THAT'S THE FOCUS OF TONIGHT'S
"ANGLE."
THE LEFT RUINS EVERYTHING IT
TOUCHES.
THEY GO SOFT ON CRIMINALS,
THEY'VE ILLINOIS LAW
LAW ENFORCEMENT.
NOW WE HAVE A MAJOR POLICE
OFFICER SHORTAGE ACROSS AMERICA.
THEY LET LEFT-WING NUT BAGS RUN
OUR SCHOOLS, THEN THE INSTITUTE
VACCINE MANDATES.
THEY GO SOFT ON STUDENT
DISCIPLINE, AND NOW WE HAVE A
MAJOR TEACHER SHORTAGE IN
AMERICA.
CONGRATULATIONS!
TODAY WE LEARNED THAT 2 MILLION
STUDENTS HAVE LEFT THE PUBLIC
SCHOOL SYSTEM ALTOGETHER BETWEEN
2020 AND 2021.
THAT IS STAGGERING.
AND IT'S NOT JUST THAT NOBODY
WANTS TO WORK IN THESE TOXIC
ENVIRONMENTS.
FEWER PEOPLE WANT TO WORK AT
ALL.
AND AGAIN, THANKS TO THE LEFT,
LIBERALS LOVED -- REMEMBER THE
COVID LOCKDOWNS, THEY ARE PAID
TO DO NOTHING, LOVED IT.
ORDERING FOOD, ZOOMING HAPPY
HOURS, PLAYING ONLINE GAMES,
BINGE WATCHING "TIGER CAN" ON
NETFLIX.
THAT WAS FUN.
SO MANY PEOPLE WERE VEGGING OUT
IN FRONT OF THE SCREENS FOR SO
MANY HOURS A DAY THEY EVEN HAD A
NAME FOR IT.
QUARANSTREAM.
AND THEY MARVELED AT HOW --
>> IF THERE'S A SILVER LINE FOR
THIS CRISIS VISIBLE IN THE SKIES
ABOVE CHINA.
>> FALLING POLLUTION LEVELS
BROUGHT ABOUT BY LOCKDOWNS MAY
HAVE BEEN SHINING AND IMPACT ON
SUNSHINE.
>> WILD ANIMALS ARE NOW ROAMING
CITY STREETS.
>> HOW DO WE MAKE SURE THESE
POLLUTION LEVELS DON'T REBOUND?
>> Laura: ALL RIGHT, THEY
WANTED TO CHANGE THE AMERICAN
PSYCHE AND IN MANY WAYS, THEY
SUCCEEDED.
STUDENTS ARE SUFFERING FROM LOST
LEARNING AND NEW ANXIETIES.
EMPLOYERS ARE SUFFERING BECAUSE
THEY CAN'T FIND WORKERS, AND
MANY OF THOSE WHO DO SHOW UP,
THEY ARE NOT HAPPY.
>> I RECENTLY LEARNED ABOUT THIS
TERM CALLED QUIET QUITTING WHERE
YOU ARE NOT OUTRIGHT QUITTING
HER JOB, YOU'RE QUITTING THE
IDEA OF GOING ABOVE AND BEYOND.
YOU'RE STILL PERFORMING YOUR
DUTIES, BUT YOU'RE NO LONGER
SUBSCRIBING TO THE HUSTLE
CULTURE MENTALITY.
THE REALITY IS YOUR WORTH AS A
PERSON IS NOT DEFINED BY OR
LABOR.
>> Laura: HE IS LOSING
MASCULINITY.
MAYBE HE DOESN'T TO FIND WORK
BUT YOUR PAYCHECK SHOULD MAYBE
BE DEFINED BY HOW MUCH YOU WORK.
PROLONGED COVID SHUTDOWNS AND
LIBERAL WORK FROM HOME POLICIES,
THEY GAVE A LOT OF WORKERS THE
NOTION THAT STAYING HOME WAS NOW
THEIR RIGHT.
AND WHO CAN BLAME THEM?
AFTER ALL, NANCY PELOSI,
SPEAKER PELOSI, THE ULTIMATE
QUEEN OF ENTITLEMENT AND
PRIVILEGE, SHE IS ALLOWED HOUSE
TO VOTE FROM HOME SINCE THE
SPRING OF 2020.
THIS PROXY VOTING SCAM WAS
SUPPOSED TO EXPIRE LAST WEEK,
BUT SHE JUST EXTENDED IT.
FOR THE 18TH TIME.
OF COURSE BECAUSE OF THE PUBLIC
HEALTH EMERGENCY.
THAT SAME EMERGENCY OF COURSE
DIDN'T STOP HER FROM TRAVELING
TO TAIWAN OR TO ITALY, AND IT'S
CERTAINLY NOT DANGEROUS ENOUGH
TO CANCEL THAT CONGRESSIONAL
BASEBALL GAME.
>> I LOVE BASEBALL, WE ARE
SEASON TICKET HOLDERS, HAVE BEEN
FOREVER.
IN THIS GAME IS SO GREAT, AND
PEOPLE ARE SO NICE.
THAT SURE MAKES IT GREAT.
BUT WE ARE COMPETITIVE AND IT'S
GREAT TO BE HERE.
HAVE A LITTLE FUN.
>> Laura: THEY WERE HOPING FOR
THE MASK THERE, BUT NO LUCK.
JUST WHEN SHE HAD HER BEAUTY
PARLOR OPEN FOR HER BLOWOUTS
DURING THE LOCKDOWNS MIGHT
REMEMBER, RULES AND EXPECTATIONS
DO NOT APPLY TO THEM.
>> DO YOU THINK THAT ANY OF YOUR
COLLEAGUES ARE USING PROXY
VOTING AS AN EXCUSE TO GET OUT
OF SHOWING UP TO WORK?
>> NO, I DON'T THINK SO.
AUGUST IS USUALLY A TIME FOR US
TO BE IN OUR DISTRICT, YOU KNOW,
IF WE CHOOSE TO TAKE A VACATION
WITH OUR FAMILIES OR SOMETHING
LIKE THAT, AUGUST IS USUALLY A
TIME FOR THAT, THAT STUFF IS
USUALLY PLANNED WAY IN ADVANCE
SO I'M SURE THERE WERE MANY
THINGS THAT PEOPLE COULDN'T
RESCHEDULE.
>> Laura: THAT'S WHAT WE'RE
DOING IT FOR THE LAST TWO YEARS.
YEAH.
WHAT AN EXAMPLE OF THESE PEOPLE
ARE SETTING FOR AMERICA.
GROCERY STORE WORKERS, AIRLINE
EMPLOYEES, THEY HAVE TO SHOW UP.
BUT THE PEOPLE'S REPRESENTATIVES
CAN'T BE BOTHERED.
THE SWAMP STRIKES AGAIN.
AND FEDERAL WORKERS?
YOU'RE GOING TO BE SHOCKED TO
KNOW THIS.
THEY DON'T WANT TO SHOW UP
EITHER.
THE OFFICE OF PERSONAL
MANAGEMENT EVEN PUSHED TELEWORK
AND THE RECENT GUIDANCE.
OPM DOESN'T CARE ABOUT HOW
TELEWORK AFFECTS THE PEOPLE WHO
ARE PAYING THE ACTUAL BILLS
THOUGH.
A FEW.
HAVE YOU TRIED TO CALL A
MEDICARE OFFICE LATELY?
QUESTIONS ABOUT YOUR PASSPORT
RENEWAL?
NIGHTMARE STORIES THERE.
BUT AGAIN, MEMBER THE BRIGHT
SIDE, IF NO ONE COMMUTES, THE
PLANET IS GOING TO BE CLEANER.
BUT THE PROGRESSIVES DIDN'T
ANTICIPATE THE UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES OF THEIR GREEN
GIDDINESS HERE.
WHAT IF THEY THINK WAS GOING TO
HAPPEN TO SUBWAYS AND URBAN LIFE
WHEN FEWER PEOPLE ACTUALLY
COMMUTE INTO THE CITIES?
EVEN A SMALL DIP IN RIDERSHIP ON
THE SUBWAY COULD SEND MASS
TRANSIT INTO BANKRUPTCY.
THERE'S ALSO SOCIOLOGICAL ASPECT
TO THE SWEDEN-LIKE OBSESSION
WITH WORK-LIFE BALANCE.
SAYS CULTURAL OBSERVER MALCOLM
GLADWELL.
>> IS VERY HARD TO FEEL
NECESSARY WHEN YOU'RE PHYSICALLY
DISCONNECTED.
I KNOW IT'S A HASSLE.
BUT YOU KNOW, IF YOU WORK -- IF
YOU'RE JUST SITTING IN THEIR
PAJAMAS IN YOUR BEDROOM, IS THAT
THE WORK-LIFE YOU WANT TO LIVE?
IF YOU DON'T FEEL LIKE WE ARE
PART OF SOMETHING APART AND,
WHAT'S THE POINT?
YOU'RE NOT JUST DOING THIS TO
GET -- IF IT'S JUST A PAYCHECK,
IT'S LIKE -- WHAT HAVE YOU
REDUCED YOUR LIFE TO?
>> Laura: BUT THE LEFT JUST
REFUSES TO THINK ABOUT ANY OF
THIS IN A RIGOROUS WAY.
THEY JUST DECLARED THAT A
FOUR-DAY WORKWEEK IS SMARTER AND
BETTER FOR THE CLIMATE.
BUT HAVE THEY STOPPED TO ASK
THAT WITH MORE LUNG WEAKENS,
WANT AMERICANS JUST CHOOSE TO
TRAVEL MORE?
HOW IS THAT GOOD FOR THE PLANET?
THE FACT OF THE MATTER IS, WHAT
THEY REALLY WANT, REALLY WANT,
IT'S FOR BUSINESSES TO HAVE NO
CHOICE.
EVENTUALLY THE ANGLE COULD SEE
GOVERNMENT MANDATES THAT FORCE
WORKERS TO STAY HOME, OR AT
LEAST A CERTAIN PERCENTAGE OF
MEN.
FATE CRISES WILL BE CITED AS A
REASON TO TAKE AWAY YOUR
FREEDOMS HERE.
IT'S A CLIMATE EMERGENCY, IT'S A
RACISM EMERGENCY, IT'S A HEALTH
EMERGENCY!
IF IT MEANS MAKING YOU POORER OR
LOWERING YOUR STANDARD OF
LIVING, GUTTING AMERICA'S
PRODUCTIVITY, SO BE IT.
IT'S NOT LIKE THE ELITES ARE
GOING TO BE INCONVENIENCED BY
ANY OF IT.
THEY'VE DONE TO OUR PUBLIC
SCHOOLS OR PUBLIC SAFETY, OUR
BORDERS, AND OUR ENERGY
INDEPENDENCE, THEY'VE DONE TO
OUR AMERICAN WORK ETHIC.
BUT WE CAN TURN THIS AROUND.
WE HAVE TO.
BY REFUSING TO SIT BACK AND WAIT
FOR SOMEONE ELSE TO DO THE HAR